you have the widest face of any Indian
I've ever seen isn't that crazy I've
been looking at a guy the whole time
like how the is he Indian yo you
look like Justin Trudeau
on Halloween
[Laughter]
I'm glad I'm in DC y'all understood that
what do you do for a living white face
oh that's what's up that's like a broke
doctor
yeah that's what's up that's what I like
to see brown love good for you guys good
for you to stay true stay true how did
you meet her
look how happy they are
you single as why don't you try
this in your parents I had to guess
who's with who you're with him you're
with him you single as well
what's going on you know that Mommy and
Daddy figure this
because this is the most Indian
ever I try to let my mom set me up and
there was a website it's a real website
it's called shopee.com Indians know it
literally means marriage.com it's like
e-harmony but we're not around
and I was like look I'm gonna let you do
this and then this she just accepted
every almost called her my bed
she accepted every doctor possible it
didn't matter if they were a
they had one leg or a kid no teeth or a
none of it mattered
she was just like no give her my chance
what do you do single
finance major
manager Financial Manager or a finance
manager
finance manager does that Majorca
Staples you've count the money in the
tilt
got the fakest jobs dude
that don't mean nothing what is a
finance manager he sent it to me like
I'm an and I should know and
then when I tried to give him a real job
Financial Manager he was like Finance
manager so my wife is my finance manager
that ain't a job that means the vice
versa is too often that's all that means
you ever met a finance manager in your
life Indian with the white girl
no good for him I hope they make it his
parents don't but I do
[Laughter]
oh you're Pakistani which she ain't
either so who gives a you're acting
like
damn bro she talk a lot
sometimes when she talks a lot for you
don't you wish you married a Muslim yeah
she's gonna ruin my career ain't
she one blog post and that's it I'm
never coming back in the city again
boyfriend what do you do for a living
oh we lost one huh
sign oh in mind if this guy dated a
white girl
finance manager who gives them you know
what I mean an HR or whatever he does
this is a fake job go and date whoever
you want to date bro we can't lose no
doctor dude what kind of
position a good kind or like a a
foot doctor
Internal Medicine you a real doctor dog
are you a doctor also
oh that's why they like you yeah she
probably wins all her cases loud as
you want to argue with that
yeah your honor guilty whatever the
she said I'm tired I can't handle this
the volume is too much yo I
can't
you're winning me over with just how
loud you are you really are I really
like it no it's really starting because
you don't give a and I do
appreciate that you can win me over with
not giving a that's a thing man
you got to that bottom of that drink yet
dog how long have you been with her that
you're drinking yourself to death slowly
6.
damn dude I did not think I was gonna
ruin your night with one question that
is a car fight bro I thought you were
looking at her because you weren't sure
if you were allowed to talk and I was
trying to empower you to speak
turns out you ain't
and that's why you don't talk because
you don't know nothing
dude what do you do for a living
God damn it white lady can you believe
these Indians dude I gave me
more like this white girl over here do
we go to law school you do got some big
traps for an Indian though is this your
is your sweater back oh yeah I
want you to stop lifting so much weight
go back to school built
like a ninja turtle for no reason what
are you doing with them trapezoids back
stop doing pull-ups pull up your GPA
[Applause]
[Music]